hey listen let me tell you something you
know one of my favorite albums of all
time i got that work by the big timers
wow that is that's crazy bro i still
underweight it bro unspoken about you
understand that it wasn't on dsps until
like four months ago and now it's on
[ __ ] i don't know there's a lot of
old cash money [ __ ] that's just
in the air somewhere i'm looking for the
remember the song on tuesdays and
thursdays you gotta why i'm looking for
the album with that on it i cannot find
it it's like tuesdays and thursdays it's
like uh
like the manny fresh uh first solo
albums not available the birdman album
what happened to that boy
was that do you remember that artwork by
the way with the half oh my god it's
kind of crazy
it's so crazy to think that that was
like flying back then like
like those those like old school
southern covers with the but that was
that one was egregious the birdman album
cover was egregious it was insane i used
to love them old covers with like the
hot boys around oh amazing james and all
of them like the soaked the shocker
charger to the game i used to never be
the biggest shocker well he was a
terrible rapper i respected him because
master p like this your brother so i'm
giving him i think silk the shocker is
the best worst rapper of all time or
or platinum he's the worst worst round
platinum before streaming
so we can't even hit him with that and
he was and
he was uh
romantically involved with maya in about
in 98 so god bless him amazing right
absolutely kudos shout out him and maya
had some joints shout out to seal yeah
he was in the video in the white jacket
and then on the snow
and slopes and [ __ ] was hard you know uh
early cash money was the best yeah [ __ ]
yeah
that's what i was at big timers though
that's the album yeah get your roll on
man it's one of my favorite songs of all
time damn peru yeah [ __ ] man that's i
feel like they still play that [ __ ] in
like commercials right
i think so i love that [ __ ]